young ryan weathers on the mount for the
san diego padres tonight at the age of
21 the youngest player in the major
league level right now
and carlson has a base hitter to right
field so amanda board two gone for the
five-time all-star nolan arenado
yanks that one down the line and is that
a fair ball home run into the corner
two-nothing saint louis
boy it got out quick
106 miles off the bat and just inside
the foul pole off the western metal
supply company corner 2-0 fastball 92
miles an hour center cut
arenado we talked about him feeling
better and swinging better
third game in a row with a home run for
arenado he has already out homered his
entire 2020 total nothing was quite
right for arenado last year in denver
the shortened season
i don't think uh
emotionally what was happening for him
in his left ear as a rocky was fixable
you're talking about a happy slugger now
who is off to a great start as a redbird
molina sends it fly ball into shallow
right that's going to be a tough play
nobody gets there
cronenworth gets it back in quickly and
holds molina to a single that one had
eyes
here's harrison bader he takes the first
pitch to the opposite field and that
one's off the wall
patrick kiplahan gets it back in and the
cardinals are busy in the first o'neill
just missed the homer on the first pitch
and a fastball you see all these
righties attacking the fastball middle
of the play weathers is throwing 93 not
97 or 98. cardinals hitters are all over
it now it's bader runners at second and
third two nothing cardinals full count
pitch on its way and bader sends a ball
into shallow center laying out is
grisham and the gold glover prevents any
further damage drink grisham coming to
get it and a big play in center field to
rob bader and take a couple of runs off
the board we'll hang a sunday night star
here petco huang yung
throwing left-hander from korea manny
with one out nobody on on the ground for
the other gold glover at the other
corner i mean it's fun to watch these
defenders gold glovers all over the
place and just
how comfortable harinado is with these
ground balls he makes it look so easy
first on the first and the cash look how
smooth and then
like a quarterback a rocket across the
infield
three hits for him last night
that one is squibber
and arenado wisely lets it roll foul
and nolan got right up on top of that
baseball to see which way it was
spinning you see so many third baseman's
trying to make a heroic play here but
this is kind of the sixth sense
in reading just like a ball in the green
what that ball is doing he knows that
ball is going to go foul an all business
start to the game by kwan young kim
the vast majority of those by the
infield as they usually are kim bunts
and the padres will cut down the lead
man
aggressive defense paying off one thing
you don't want to do is put the ball in
the hands of another platinum winner
machado with the confidence the former
shortstop throws a strike too easy for
machado
and he got him to strike out first of
the game for
kwan jung kim so he's getting it and
he's throwing it
back-to-back strikeouts for him here in
the third two outs of the base is empty
for ryan weathers there's the two and
two that's a ground ball up the middle
and into center field a base hit first
of the big leagues for ryan weathers a
two out single here in the third inning
and that stops a streak of eight
straight retired by kwang on kim to
start the game
that one's heading home to tennessee
being authenticated before our very eyes
wow and kim gets a call on a breaking
ball around the corner that is uh three
strikeouts in the inning and all three
strikeouts were on pitches that were not
in the zone so man on first nobody out
for jake cronenberg
this is slow ground ball to second
edmond will try and tag manny he missed
him and manny ends up up ending him
and now they pat each other on the back
side manny was never out manny stopped
in between first and second edmond
charged at him but missed the tag i
don't think manny realized that but
machado got up and tried to get to
second base he might have been safe
bases are loaded here with one gone
and a big opportunity for the rookie
marcano and error will walk in a single
of low to the bases and there's ball
four the padres are on the board on a
bases loaded wall
all right so here is kim versus kim part
two with a run in and the base is loaded
full count to hassan kim
wow
a guy that just doesn't want anybody has
walked three in the inning including two
with the bases loaded and this game is
tied
two runs in base is still loaded and
only one gun
kevlahan off the end of the back
chasing bader who sets up in deeper
right center field to make the catch
it's going to score the go-ahead run in
austin nola and it's 3-2 san diego two
balls and two strikes to castillo
there's a shot into right field that's
gonna bring in another score
yvonne castillo's first big league hit
is good for an rbi and a four to two
padres lead runners at first and third
now with nobody out to start the sixth
inning against lumet
did it
great play by marcano to second for one
and they turned the double play
st louis does score a run as goldschmidt
comes in but the pods would gladly trade
the run for the pair of outs
here's trent grisham now over three so
far tonight
grisham slashes that one into left field
oh man and it gets over o'neal
kevlahan coming around
that was an absolute rocket off the back
and it just sailed right over a gold
glover in left
here is mark malenson
13 for 13. we talked about how good alex
reyes has been out of the saint louis
bullpen melanson has been even better
perfect in 13 opportunities and it will
come down to tommy edmond
who puts it in play up the first base
line malanson flips to cronenworth and
that'll do it the san diego padres
complete their first three-game sweep of
the cardinals
in a decade
a 5-3 victory
wrapping things up tonight